all right everyone I'm Ilana and holy
crap III is this week my body is not
ready seriously I'm like breaking out
because of stress it's intense so I'm
gonna make this video to tell everyone
who's been asking where you can find me
what live streams on doing what coverage
I'm doing and there is a lot of it
so my EP is kind of starting on Friday
night because I'm doing scared to kick a
charity where much people play scary
games a bunch of the game grumps are
doing it to read my ticket so I'm doing
that at 5 p.m. on Friday twitch.tv slash
Gattaca I'm really excited to be
involved in that so on Saturday the EA
conference starts at noon and we think
God still about 1:30 we're doing a
preacher and a post show on again I will
be on that show so the pre-show will be
talking about predictions until you want
to see from that conference we'll jump
right into the conference and then have
a post show what will kind of deceptive
stuff that we saw pretty shots of the
lemon pusher we'll start as soon as the
conference fascias and end at around
2:30 p.m. to tell you where you can
watch that conference though one thing
I'm pretty excited about is that I Jan
is potted with Twitter so this year we
have live streaming on Twitter you can
watch it all on Twitter otherwise
identical youtube.com slash IGN or
twitch.tv slash IGN hold easy places to
watch this stuff so I had to anyone
who's following me on Twitter I tweet so
much during e3 if you don't want to see
it just just mute me just gonna be a lot
about video games and then Saturday
night which I'm pretty excited about is
I Jan's meet-and-greet so any of you
happen to be in LA I can come and hang
out I'll probably be there from around 6
to 8 because I am gonna want to go to
bed super early it's at the Belasco
Ballroom in now to downtown LA so if
you're in that area for sure come and
say hi that would be awesome
Sunday I'm starting my day off with some
stuff I can't tell you about just yet
but it's pretty exciting then I am on
the Microsoft pre-show Microsoft
conference is 2 p.m. to 3:30 p.m. so we
thank free shows up at 1:00 p.m. and the
post show will be immediately after the
conference ends and the 4:30 p.m. then I
might be doing some normal live show
develop it interview stuff or edging in
on the same stream stuff that we haven't
walked down there's one thing I miss
listed in here
I don't know it's Game one so we aren't
even allowed to know what it is we just
know that we need to cover it and then
the best conference is that night which
I might be going to alright Monday at
Ubisoft press conference from 1:00 p.m.
to 2:30 p.m. our pre-show starts at noon
again I'm on it and then that night the
sunny I'm actually going on Jeff Keely
show again I get xbox watches this year
I'm doing PlayStation pre-show for that
should start at around 5:30 I believe I
don't know as much details because
obviously that's a separate company than
the one that I work for but it's
basically you should gaming why so
you'll be able to find that on YouTube
so but everything else in my schedule I
can't really tell you guys what I'm
doing um
because some things hasn't been
announced yet but it will be part of
IGN's live programming that you guys
will be able to watch and I'll be active
on all of the social medias I'm crazy
excited about it I bought a ton of new
clothes I've been playing loads of video
games from franchises that I expect to
be there this year so for predictions I
pulled out the top three that people
have been asking me what is what I'm
most excited about shooting he referring
to games I would say see your feet I
really want to know if there's a main
quest how that game looks if you want
just playing with a group of friends or
group people that you know what happens
if I got a voice chat SuperMario Odyssey
I think we have an appointment to play
that actually so I'm really excited
about that
mostly because I haven't water switch
yet and I'm planning to sometime soon I
decided I'm going to next time I go to
Australia just trade in a ton of my
games can be really hard for me to do
that but if I can buy a switch and I
don't know what I'm in for maybe what
time I should buy depending on when
we're gonna see comes out and the third
one is probably spider-man on ps4 it's
made by the same team who made
sunset overdrive if you haven't played
that it is so much fun it should so it's
mentioned that it kind of starts off
with a lot of tutorials so it's slow at
the beginning but once you get like
three hours in it's so easy to just
spend a ton of time playing it because
it's it's just boss the biggest
prediction that people keep asking about
is what I think of scope yo and
what it's going to cost I think it's
going to cost $4.99 I don't think it's
going to be the same price as the PS pro
it's going to be more expensive they
keep saying it is a premium console it
needs premium pricing and I probably
won't buy it
same reason is everything else I don't
have enough money but it's also just
like I don't have a 4k TV and I've never
had all that much in that resolution so
it's not something that I'm going to run
out the door again but I think it's
probably going to be the centerpiece of
the Xbox's conference probably along
with fourth serve I really hope they
have a bunch of new IPs and ones that
are coming out soon as well so many I
think it's going to be an interesting
press conference because so many
incredible games came out this year
already horizon personifies Nia Nia
that's just in the first six months of
this year those are games are like you
could just buy those four and you'd be
set for an entire year because they're
all really meaty as well so we're
probably going to go to war which I see
more of I don't care about days gone it
could probably sell me on it but right
now it just looks like another zombie
game obviously spider-man but I'm
wondering what else we might see this
coming out soon because I'm kind of
feeling like with the way Sony's lineup
is walking we probably won't have
anything that is going to come out in
the next 12 months in $10 I mean ever
almost the Metroid's that's the way it
is I personally want a Pokemon snap or
an email I plug them on on switch but
both of those people all right it is 120
and if I'm speaking quietly because I'm
trying not to wake people sorry about
that
I am Ilana I'll see you guys next time
all right